Film Courage: When you sit down to write a
story do you start with a treatment or an
outline? Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer:
Now each process has been a little bit different
for me. For each one I've done quite a bit
with treatments and outlines but they're very
useful. But what I found more useful is what
we talked about before, the movie days that's
helped me give it a structure but I would come
with an idea and sometimes it depends on each
script sometimes. I'll let it flow and just kind
of I'll have an ending and I'll have an image and
we'll start from there but then maybe one month
later I'll start an outline because I'm stuck.
But I like to be flexible on that in my routine
on just depending on because some stories come
out i think it's like writing i can only imagine
if it's like writing music some some songs you
always hear those great songs whether it's Dolly
Parton doing something like nine to five in like
two minutes or something like that or like or
like someone oh i just walked into the night
and just wrote this master's piece sometimes it
pours out sometimes it's laborious um but again
um so i you know i think those are useful
treatments and not online so definitely
that was a great movie too yeah oh nine
to five oh yeah yeah that's great with
your film all roads to perla it started with an
idea from seeing a paper bag or a plastic bag
yeah well i had an image of that i also
had an image of the texas landscape
and i had the feeling of this wide open space uh
at night and and i knew that one of the characters
was uh a wrestler and during when your
wrestling season i used to wrestle
sometimes you would sleep in a plastic bag
and then i had these images of plasti uh
you know there's a plastic bag hanging in a tree
sometimes when you drive around in the desert
and things like that are out out there you'll see
that so it it started what with with the landscape
seeing plastic and then having that feel
of than i thought of plastic bag body bags
um than i thought which was all because of day
jamming you think you start you driving your your
date well i told you not to drive and daydream but
i was on the road a lot for for my assignments and
you're covering texas i covered like 5 000 miles
in 21 days to do like 18 shoots one time and that
was how all roads are paralyzed sort of coming
out um it's because i saw all these places and
faces and i didn't want that to end you know so
i would just combine them and create my own story
and were you doing a full loop around texas
the outskirts i did i've probably i've probably
seen more of texas and texans i've been to
eagle pass brownsville um midlands petcos
um everything for just uh all different types of
assignments so uh and that's that that's why that
landscape to me had so much like mystery so much
history and and and it was just like wow this is
this is unbelievable you know it's like you
hear stories of you know cowboys and this but
to actually see that land it was awesome you know
and the people and and the culture uh you can't
yeah i was definitely inspired by by that and then
i did and then i was sent down to houston to do
um uh a story and then that tied in to what i was
doing and in houston there's this two mile stretch
where there are these massage parlors
illegal massage parlors and then i was in um
i got to go on a raid with sheriff so i
would i would have all these like interesting
heavy assignments um whether it's
immigration to that to uh exoneree
the michael morton he was accused of killing his
wife served uh like 22 years in death row but
later found out that he didn't do it so all these
human interest stories i i wanted to understand
um it you know what that was all about we make
these choices and sometimes those choices aren't
good enough and and then we um we have to live
with the consequences good or bad so that's what
happened in my time driving around in texas how
did you feel let's say you get out at a road stop
go to use the bathroom at an older gas station or
you stop for a bite to eat at a cafe i mean like
how was that you're just interacting with
it's interesting being an asian american
enjoying this of going around a different like i
think i went to the least populated county once
population like 10 or something like that
um uh it's cool it's cool it's it's again
um i felt like i was uh like in in in a movie
all the time i felt like it was but it's real
it's awesome it's uh the people the culture again
i keep talking about that um but when i would stop
it's sort of like when you get so used to thinking
what could happen like if these laws could talk
who lived here 20 years ago 40 years ago what
what family you know it's the same thing what
happened this stop what happened in this single
single-family home who owned it before so your
brain just goes all over the place and i think
um working as a photographer i was able to catch
it with one frame but now as like you you could
write you could write these stories and just make
it up you know like oh this is what happened
fred walked out the door got hit by a truck
his son's out for revenge there okay now let's
have fun and let's spend next two hours writing
about that why who was who hid in the track was
there a motive what fred do that other person you
know it's so that's that's kind of neat and that
helps with if you daydream a lot because then you
just go oh what happens over there well maybe fred
you know had it coming well that's what the mayor
said well the sheriff is about to you know just
so good you can keep going it's it's fascinating
interesting on being on the road you you i think
we're where we behave differently too if for let's
say i took a greyhound across country one time
as a kid and you if you're in your own car versus
you're in you know waiting in line at an airport
or something and you just you're seeing all these
people and you're imagining what their lives are
like and they're looking at you thinking the same
thing you know and it's just i don't know we're
just in a different mindset i think when we travel
even just domestically you know so anyway yeah
when you're seeing like you know i would walk
when i was in new york or anywhere even here and
you walk by so many people and you're just like
i wonder i wonder what their are we ever going
to meet again then you're like i wonder how many
photos i'm in in the background that you know that
i don't know of and things like that and you then
you realize how many people are in this world and
then you realize how many um stories there are
but then you're like we're all human we have
these same emotions how do we tap on into that
and that's why when you hear music and songs
that could move a whole country a whole world
that is amazing to have write something in three
minutes to have something play in three minutes
and it just moves everyone um yeah mozart
or anything like that elvis elvis and and
and beatles so which means we're connected in
a certain way we're connected with emotions
um so i think when we travel though we see
different things different lands different people
who are still connected with those human
emotions and things you know that's that's
what the fun part is as a creator so um i grew
up um and if uh from i'm from laos my grandmother
um came to the states in 1986 she didn't
know any english so and my allow is
not great the greatest so it's for us to
communicate was there's other other ways maybe
that's why i like filmmaking or photography
it was other ways to communicate there's
were like she would i would try to have to
translate general hospital to her and why
luke and laura got married and things like that
in lao and it was funny so when you when you with
another language and you got to find other ways
to communicate maybe that i got so into visuals
into into sounds so those are things that could
express things versus literally i am sad you know
i'm telling you i'm sad versus like uh a frown you
know so that kind of stuff so it's it's it's neat
you